what's the newest language you use I
would say the newest language I use is
go and that is sort of 10 years old at
this point
language is last longer than you think
Fortran which dates from the late 50s is
still very much alive and still very
much used by a lot of people as is
Cobalt
Algol lives on in just derivatives basic
moves on its derivatives so all these
languages never die but then there are
brand new languages that come along I
think that of languages that anybody
might have heard of that I used today
yeah go would probably be the newest I
have experimented with other languages
briefly mostly to try and understand
them just enough that I can say
something in class rust is newer than C
but not enormous ly so so I done that
Scala I don't even remember the dates
but it started called contemporaneous
with go I've done one program in that
one in Lua I do our languages like
Kotlin no I've never tried sorry late
follower not an early adopter any
functional stuff I've seen your views on
function before but it'd be interesting
to capture yeah my functional languages
are really really important I think
because what they are have proven to be
is a proving ground for ideas in
programming so a lot of the things that
we take for granted in modern languages
mainstream languages mainstream compiled
languages like let's say C++ or Java or
gold whatever many of the good ideas the
new ideas and those came from functional
languages for example recursion
originally is a lisp idea and it shows
up everywhere functions as first-class
citizens pattern matching kinds of thing
all of these show up in functional
languages and then move into the
mainstream in some way I have never
gotten over the hurdle of really
internalizing a functional language well
I have tried Haskell it was a desperate
desperately bad time it took me two
weeks to write a program that took me
probably an hour to write in Luo another
language I had never tried in my life I
am not cut out there's something wrong
to mean my brain and Haskell I I can't
do it but that's not to say that Haskell
is a bad idea it has many neat ideas and
it undoubtedly is providing something
that will help people in the future in
programming but I think mainstream use
is probably always going to be dominated
by the more conventional compile
imperative sorts of languages the chap
who asked the question about newest
language goes on to say what would you
like to see created which i think is a
tricky thing but you know what would you
take the best doll from and is there a
way to answer that I think the way I
would answer it is to say that in many
cases the way we make progress and all
of these language related things is when
we get to this stage where what we're
trying to say is so mechanical you can
almost say it mechanically and once you
get to that stage and I say well let's
mechanize it so we'll add something
whether it's a language or a library or
something like that so that a whole
class of things that used to require us
to do it over and over again have now
become something where you have a
specification or a very simple language
and the language is taken care of a lot
of it that has the advantage you
understand it better it's much more
likely to be right if a computer is
doing it for you and it's probably
easier to teach it to other people as
well and sometimes those languages are
declarative sometimes they're procedural
but fundamentally I think that's the way
we make progress we understand more of
it what it is we want to do and how to
express how to do that and then we put
that into a program we mechanize it John
Reid asks if you could start from
scratch today and build a new processor
architecture or protein system with what
we know today where would you begin and
what would it look like I would begin by
getting somebody who actually knows what
that's all about sorry I mean it's true
it's not my thing I'm no expert it's
fair answer and he goes on to ask a
second question we'll block-based
drag-and-drop programming like scratch
eventually replace traditional
text-based programming that I at least
have opinions on um I think the answer
is no I played briefly with scratch or
at least a derivative there was a
program that our system that Google
provided called App Inventor
the idea was that it was basically
scratch but with primitives that made it
possible to build Android apps very
easily and my experience with that was
that for anything that fit within the
model for which they had provided the
blocks was perfectly fine but very very
very clunky I tried to build something
that would navigate around a building
for example and doing a distance
computation with blocks was just you had
this much block to say give me the
square-root-of-x-squared-plus-y-squared
it was hopeless so I think using
languages like scratch as they were
constituted when I did this this was a
while ago so maybe it's moved on but I
think the problem with them is it's
trying to sort of like trying to get to
the moon by climbing a tree you know the
first 10 or 20 feet is really good now
you're stuck okay getting to work and I
think the same thing is true no that's
for me as a sort of professional
programmer trying to do things as a way
to introduce programming kids absolutely
great there's amazing stuff that people
do with scratch and languages like that
could you do something that would use
the block pace part as something that is
a nice way to get started with aspects
of it and then extend it in other ways
that's what I was trying to do when I
was playing with App Inventor and it
just it founded on the technology there
but I think something like that might be
useful so they have their place but it's
not gonna replace other languages well
do you think about this is such a wide
wide brief what do you think about the
future of computer science will the
manipulating bits era become obsolete in
a few years or basics will never change
I think basics will always be there in
some sense we will always have to worry
about how much memory we have how much
processor time we have we'll have to
worry about whether the programs are
correct or not whether they're safe and
secure or not so all of that is going to
be with us I think in perpetuity and I
think and as a nominally computer
science educator that's something that
we want to make sure those so that
students in computer science courses
let's say at university should actually
understand the basics at that point they
should understand how the machines work
what the limitations and realities are
of making
do things they should also understand
some of the theoretical limitations some
things are hard to compute intrinsically
and that's important and sometimes
useful so all of that kind of thing is
going to be there so let's call that
core computer science and then there's
all the things that computer science
gets applied to and that's the place
where all the growth is in some sense I
used to say to students in one of my
classes for non-technical people I don't
care what your major or field is you'll
find a use for computing unless maybe
you're a religion major and then I
realized this is nonsense religion
majors do really really interesting
analysis of texts written in ancient
languages and there did the same kind of
authorship questions that showed up in a
more recent issues like the Federalist
Papers all of these kinds of things so I
don't care what your field is it has
computing in it the more you know about
that the better off you'll be able to do
things in your field that's a fantastic
answer I'm gonna ask you on the silly
ones now what is the proper way to
pronounce caramel is it caramel or
caramel I think it's a three syllable
word caramel to me but I think so I
don't know now that you asked me not
necessary silly ones but very difficult
to answer in a concise way what are your
favorite books or what are your top few
books this came up a couple of times
yeah when I think about what I read and
let's call it reading for pleasure as
opposed to reading for work I think what
I find myself reading mostly is either
junky detective stories one of the
wonderful things about spending time in
England is charity shops there are
charity shops everywhere in every town
no matter how big or small and you can
go in there and buy for a pound a really
really interesting junky detective story
that you hadn't read already and then in
the next town having read it you drop it
off at the charity shop and pick up a
new one so I read a lot of those kinds
of things probably half to two-thirds by
British authors and the rest by American
authors so though I read those the other
thing that I read and probably this is
more at home tends to be history the one
sort or another
the Princeton library has a great
collection of history books and so I
find myself reading that reading things
on the Second World War just before I
left I'm carrying a copy of a distant
mirror which Barbara Tuchman wrote years
ago what calamitous arrow the 14th
century and so on which has a lot of
English and French and a Crusades Hey so
lots of these things that's that's what
I read for fun as opposed to for work I
think I don't do very much reading of
technical books other than occasionally
I will buy a book on something like how
do you use react or how do you program
for Androids or I got one on Oh camel
recently because in spite of saying I
don't know anything about functional
languages I figure out how to learn
something and unfortunate I'm not sure
I've opened it yet so technical books I
know I don't read as much as I probably
should in every respect but very much
more pragmatic in a way so things are
influenced by what went before
and sometimes it's wow we need more of
that and sometimes it's a we need less
of that and do something different so